dr biden it's a pleasure and honor to
speak with you
many of you have had to make some major
adjustments
in order to serve our communities this
year i know our volunteers are looking
forward
to uh post covert world what is one
thing you like to do
uh coping a fun thing
a fun thing yes i don't know maybe go
have a martini and some french fries
yes i knew i loved you
i love that idea how about you what do
you want to go do
uh i want to actually get back on the
basketball court and play basketball
you know as an old man it gives me a lot
of energy to play with some of my young
guys
just to build a relationship and to be
able to let them know that tomorrow's
gonna be a better day and to your point
there is opportunity
uh in crisis uh we were dealing with a
pandemic of poverty long before the
coronavirus
and so just giving hope uh and and
incentive to young people that
you can't be great and tomorrow's gonna
be a better day yep absolutely you're
right
god bless you for you know for what
you're doing thank you